hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt auch
heute wieder in meiner kategorie was
koche ich heute ich koche heute eine
leckere karotten kartoffelsuppe dazu
gezeigt welchen und geröstetes brot und
ich zeige euch jetzt erst mal wie man
die suppe ansätze in der zwischenzeit
werde ich die hackbällchen zubereitet
und ganz zum schluss eben das brot dann
ist alles gleichzeitig fertig und wir
können das alles gleichzeitig essen
also ich habe hier eine rote zwiebel 400
gramm karotten wobei ich jetzt hier etwa
350 gramm karotten und noch etwas
petersilienwurzel habe für den
intensiveren geschmack dann habe ich
hier 400 gramm kartoffeln dessen mehlig
kochende ich habe etwas ingwer ein liter
gemüsebrühe und olivenöl und hier habe
ich noch curry und chili zum abschmecken
etwas muskatnuss salz und pfeffer ich
habe jetzt das alles schon geschält und
dabei habe ich auch das geschehene
gewicht beachtet also 400 gramm
geschälte karotten zum beispiel jetzt
sehe ich zuerst mal die zwiebel und die
würfel ich und ich mach das jetzt alles
hier mit dem würfel ihr könnt es aber
natürlich auch mit einem messer
jetzt gebe ich schon mal olivenöl in
einem topf und gibt da auch irgendwann
mit dazu den habe ich einfach ganz grob
gewürfelt
und gäbe es hier auch direkt die zwiebel
mit rein dann dürfen die einfach mit dem
inga zusammen ein bisschen anbraten
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal die karotten gibt mir dass sie die
wurzel und die kartoffeln würfeln und
petersilienwurzel das ist richtig
intensiv im geschmack und gibt einfach
die suppe zu diese würze
also ich finde sie richtig gut
jetzt gebe ich das gemüse mit in den
topf
und da lasse ich das jetzt einfach so
etwa zwei minuten mit anbraten
jetzt lasse ich das gemüse mit der brühe
und dann darf das einfach mit
geschlossenem deckel kochen und zwar so
etwa 15 bis 20 minuten bis das gemüse
weich ist und in der zwischenzeit
richtig jetzt schon mal die hackbällchen
für die hackbällchen braucht ihr findet
gramm hackfleisch starb jetzt rinder
hackfleisch zwei scheiben toast ob das
werde ich gleich noch mit etwas wasser
übergießen
also etwas einweichen 1 1 hier habe ich
etwas klein geschnittene petersilie
levi's aus dem gefrierfach von mir dann
habe ich hier curry oregano chili salz
und pfeffer und es war es im prinzip
auch schon als ich nehme jetzt zuerst
das toastbrot und es könnte jetzt
entweder in milch einweichen oder
einfach mit etwas wasser ich mach das
jetzt mit wasser um das es kurz stehen
und nehmen schon mal das hackfleisch und
gibt es in der schüssel und das und auch
die petersilie 28 ii vom hochbeet vom
sommer und so kann ich dir mal ganz vor
außerdem aus dem gefrierfach und dann
einfach benutzen wenn ich frische
petersilie krachen
es gebe hier ein bisschen carey mit rein
aber wirklich nicht viel sondern auch
dann ein esslöffel oregano chili gibt
ihr nach wir leben rein also gerne etwas
mehr oder weniger je nachdem wie ihr das
gerne mögt und einen teelöffel salz
da kann ich auch das rot schon
ausdrücken
gibt es dann auch direkt mit rein
und da lass ich die zutaten einfach in
der küchenmaschine kurz durchkneten
und jetzt kann ich da kleine
hackbällchen fordern die können da jetzt
so groß oder zu klein machen wie ihr
gerne möchte ich habe sie jetzt so etwa
2 cm groß
in
die hackbällchen kann ich jetzt in etwas
olivenöl anbraten
sie brauchen dazu etwa 45 minuten ihr
müsst ihr einfach immer wieder drehen
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal das parkett vorbereiten
dafür gebe ich etwas olivenöl auf eine
back folie oder auch ein backpapier und
habe jetzt hier acht scheiben baguette
und die tongestein
und dann kommen die bei 210 grad in den
vorgeheizten backofen so für etwa fünf
bis sechs minuten
um es einfach schauen dass wir eine
schöne farbe bekommen
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr dafür
noch mehr geschmack einfach eine
knoblauchzehe aufschneiden und die dann
aufs brot streichen
aber so ein bisserl einreiben
oder ihr legte einfach in scheiben
brauch aber da kann es dann das einfach
verbrannt
deswegen finde ich die variante etwas
besser
gibt an der stelle kann ich schon mal
die suppe abschmecken geduckte jetzt
nämlich schon etwa 15 minuten kochen
das heißt ich gebe da jetzt auch ein
bisschen curry mit rein mini das mögt
dann etwas chili und muskat demokratisch
tochter jetzt kommt noch etwas pfeffer
mit rein und salzen nur bei bedarf als
er falls die gemüsebrühe schon salzig
man müsste einfach schauen ob es als
benötigt oder nicht und da kann ich
jetzt erstmal die suppe pürieren mit
einem kurier statt
das brot ist jetzt auch fertig und jetzt
kann ich alles anrichten
deswegen ist die suppe gebe ich jetzt in
so einem schildchen ein schild ich mag
sie suchen so bisschen deftiger sind ja
und ich aus entwickler das mag ich auch
ganz gern so und die hackfleischbällchen
die spielt sich jetzt auf dann kann man
die schönen trümmer legen
3com 3 erreicht werden
33 dann mache ich den spieß mittel
kleiner
dann gehe ich dir das so toll und dann
kriegst du noch geröstetes brot mit dazu
irgendwas ist anders
bitte schön dass werner teller oder
wahnsinnig schönen teller gekriegt hab
ich jetzt extra für dich angerichtet
lichter der stadt stimmten großen
hochzeitsfeier oder nee ich habe
eigentlich nur einem von dem teller aber
ich wollte jetzt auch schön anrichte und
später nach rechts fürs foto halt mal
was so wow ich bin ganz bei kriegt man
sonst beschwert dass ich wenn ich das
jetzt einfach fürs foto angerichtet
hätte ohne ihnen normale teller gegeben
hätte dann beschwert sich weiß ist eben
das netz mit sony gar nicht glauben ich
mich auf etwas hinweisen alles gut
geburtstag hinein ok ich würde gerne
schuhe kaufen es ist durchaus jeden
fleischbällchen der rhein gucken und du
kannst du auch vom städtchen runter
essen.de aus rein machst du rein
ich hab's ja auch mittel kleiner gemacht
deswegen kriegt einen schön angerichtet
eller weil er immer gleich ein derart
gestört
okay ich habe probiert und durch diese
petersilienwurzel in der suppe ist die
halt richtig schön deftig und würzig und
sich auch sehr cremig ich habe da jetzt
auch keine sahne oder sowie drin also
die summe an sich ist ja eigentlich rein
vegan durch die aktuelle team ist
natürlich kein begabungsgerecht mehr und
das geröstete brot mit dem knoblauch
wenig passt einfach perfekt dazu super
super kartoffel karotte und
petersilienwurzel
der murat gelistet weiter seine suppe
oder möchte schon gekostet so anmerken
und wenn ihr das rezept nach machen
wollt geht einfach auf cds - dach des
lebens noch mal
und ja ich freue mich dass nach macht
und wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachkochen und wir sehen uns das nächste
mal wieder hakt die die kette müller ist
noch richtig lecker katar ist das könnte
bullard um das nette geht es bei ikea
das kennt man doch auch mal mache ich
jetzt ja